Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass, es ist wieder soweit. Wir blicken auf die internationalen Ligen der Männer, die Ligatur ist zurück. Ich weiß, dass ihr euch genauso freut wie ich. Und deswegen lasst uns jetzt gleich starten hier mit Rasenfunk Kurzpass 243. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und hallo und herzlich willkommen an meine geliebte Ligaturen Runde. Ich begrüße zu meiner Linken in den Headquarters Christian Bernhardt. Hallo Christian.
Hallo Max, hallo in die Runde.
Er ist extrem euphorisch, das kann ich euch sagen. Genauso wie Alex Truica. Hallo Alex. Und dann haben wir noch am Telefon zugeschaltet, wie bei einer Außenwette bei Wetten das. Alexi Menuge, hallo Alexi. Schön, dass ihr alle da seid. Es war eine zu lange Pause. Ich weiß es, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr habt es mir auch gespiegelt. Aber damit ist es jetzt vorbei. Wir haben große Pläne für die Ligatur. Jetzt wird sie regelmäßiger erscheinen. Ich will noch nicht ankündigen, in welchem Rhythmus, denn der muss sich jetzt erstmal bei uns allen einspielen. Aber es wird einen Rhythmus geben und es wird nicht wieder so lange zur nächsten Sendung dauern. Wie immer der kurze Hinweis, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe- paywall und sponsorenfrei. Alles, was wir hier machen und auch die Honorare, die wir unseren Gästen zahlen, die finanzieren sich ausschließlich aus eurer freiwilliger Unterstützung auf rasenfunk.de slash supportersclub. Da könnt ihr erfahren, wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt. Und ein Hinweis, wir sind jetzt eine GmbH und unsere Konto-Verbindung hat sich verändert. Das heißt, wenn ihr noch einen laufenden Dauerauftrag habt, dann geht unbedingt auf rasenfunk.de slash Konto, denn alles Geld, was auf das alte Konto ankommt, das können wir nicht verwenden, um Rechnungen für den Rasenfunk zu bezahlen, weil wir uns verändert haben. Wenn euch interessiert, warum wir das gemacht haben, dazu gibt es eine eigene Schlusskonferenz. Frank und ich haben da ausführlich darüber gesprochen, warum wir jetzt so was wie eine GmbH sind. Und es fühlt sich auch immer noch komisch an. Aber gut, Christian kann bezeugen, es hat sich hier nichts verändert. Kein vergoldeter Boden seit…
Ja, also ist auf jeden Fall spannend, die Konstellation. Wie gesagt, auch Monza wirklich in sehr guter Form. Ich kann aber auch jedem nur am Freitag Sassuolo gegen Napoli ans Herz legen, weil was Napoli weiterhin macht, ist einfach herausragend. Und Sassuolo hat sich auch wieder gefangen, hat ihm zuletzt diese fünf Stückchen San Siro und Milan eingeschenkt. Eine sehr spielstarke Mannschaft. Bin gespannt, ob die ein Mittel gegen dieses sehr beeindruckende Napoli finden.
Freitag ist das ganz gut, weil vielleicht hat ja dann Alex kein Freitagsspiel. Alex, welches La Liga-Spiel sollten wir uns zu Gemüte führen?
Eigentlich hast du es schon genannt. Das Spiel der Spiele ist heute Abend in der Europa League und weniger in der Liga. Barca gegen Man Utd. Kommt vielleicht für den einen oder anderen Hörer zu spät, wenn ihr die Episode anhört. Dann würde ich ihm ans Herz legen, vielleicht die Woche oder dieses Wochenende eher nur so neben Beilerliga zu folgen und den richtigen Fokus dann aber nächste Woche legen. Nicht nur auf dann Man Utd. Barca mit genügend Vorlaufzeit, sondern nächste Woche ist das Madrid der Stadtderby Real Madrid gegen Atletico, also Samstag, 25.02. Das ist das Spiel. Der Spiele kann man jetzt nicht so sagen. Atletico war dafür zuletzt nicht gut genug. Aber in diesem Wochenende gibt es nicht so das Spiel Barca, zum Beispiel nur zu Hause gegen Cardis. Pflichtgemäß ist 1 zu 0, könnte es da geben. Würde ich jetzt schon sagen. Real Madrid hatten schwere Spiele und Osasuna, aber da würde ich jetzt auch nicht sagen, versammelt euch zwingend vor dem Fernseher. Vielleicht eher dann bei United oder eben die Woche drauf beim Madrid der Derby.
Okay, also ich hätte jetzt gesagt, allein von der Tabellenkonstellation her, Atletico gegen Bilbao, also gegen Atletiq Bilbao, aber...
Normalerweise von den Namen der Verein, ja, aber das kann halt auch immer ein sehr unansehnliches 0-0 werden. Da weiß man bei Atletico ja nie. Also du kannst natürlich auch da Spektakel haben, weil Atletico auch immer für verrückte Dinge steht, also irgendwie Notbremse in der 9. Minute. Dann spielen sie in Unterzahl, dann schießen sie in der 91. das 1-0 und in der 93. kassieren sie das 1-1. Auch dafür sind sie in den letzten Jahren gut, aber ob es jetzt sportlich der Leckerbissen wird, bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher. Deswegen konnte ich es nicht einfach sofort empfehlen, das Spiel.
Okay, dann lasse ich dich damit auch davon kommen und stelle abschließend noch die Frage an Alexi. Was sollten wir im Blick behalten in der Ligue 1 am Wochenende?
Ja, der Sonntag vor allem, weil um 13 Uhr haben wir Paris Saint-Germain gegen Lille. Und Paris könnte zum vierten Mal in Folge verlieren gegen eine Mannschaft, die den ansinnlichsten Fußball bietet in der Liga mit einem wieder ehemaligen Serie A-Trainer, mein lieber Christian, Paulo van Zylker, der eine tolle Arbeit macht in Nordfrankreich. Und dann wird es noch enger für Christophe Galti, der Trainer von PSG. Um 13 Uhr ist es ungefähr die Uhrzeit, wo normalerweise eine EM aufsteht. Und abends auch, von Natima Säe haben wir schon thematisiert, aber ich bin in Toulouse und diese Mannschaft könnte man nächstes Mal thematisieren bei diesem Aussteiger. Ich bin auch in einem überragenden Fußball, voll im Offensive ausgerichtet, einer der besten Angriffe der Liga. Und ich glaube, ich werde zoraus und einen schönen Sonntagabend kann man dann erleben.
Und natürlich wegen der Anschlusszeit. Das ist natürlich frech, dass dann ein Nehmer früher aufstehen muss. Ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Danke an Alexis Menuge. Danke an Alex Truica. Sehr gerne. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Und danke, lieber Christian Bernhard. Schön, dass du hier warst. Und wir machen an der Stelle jetzt weiter mit der Premier League. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß dabei. Jetzt begrüße ich bei mir Jogi Hebel, die Legende. Er ist hier. Hallo Jogi, schön, dass du Zeit für die Ligatur hast.
Bei Legende bin ich jetzt fast vom Stuhl gefallen, aber gerne.
Ja, es wird ein Legendensegment. Zumindest werden wir uns mit der Premier League auseinandersetzen. Und da beginnen wir aktuell. Denn bisher war es ein Kopf-an-Kopf-Rennen zwischen Arsenal und City. Um die Tabellenführung. Arsenal war schon ein bisschen davon gekommen, aber jetzt ist am gestrigen Abend – wir nehmen am Donnerstag, den 16. Februar auf – etwas passiert, was eben dazu geführt hat, dass jetzt zumindest stand, jetzt Manchester City aktueller Tabellenführer ist und Arsenal eingeholt ist, zumindest für den Moment. Denn die beiden hatten ein Nachholspiel, und das hat City mit 3 zu 1 gewonnen. Was sind denn die Erkenntnisse aus dieser Partie?
Ja, dass Arsenal einfach noch nicht so stabil ist, wie man glaubte. Die hatten wirklich einen guten Start, aber jetzt kommt wieder diese wunderschöne Floskel. In der Saison ist das einfach ein Marathon und kein Sprint. Die sind sehr, sehr gut aus den Startlöchern gekommen, aber in den letzten Wochen hat es einfach wirklich nicht mehr gut. Das muss man klar sagen. Sie sind gegen Elberton verloren. Sie haben dann unentschieden gespielt am Wochenende gegen Brentford, auch wenn das jetzt nicht mit rechten Dingen zugegangen ist, muss man wirklich fairerweise sagen, und haben jetzt halt wieder verloren. Das sind drei Spiele, ein Stück, in den sie jetzt einfach nicht gewonnen haben. Und dann merkt man auch diese Stabilität. Ja, ein Tommy Yasu, dessen Scouting-Bericht sagt, seine größte Stärke ist, dass er keine Fehler macht. Und genau der spielt den Ball direkt auf Kevin de Boijne. Dann natürlich auch noch fälscht er den zweiten ab. Also sie waren dann einfach auch irgendwann in der zweiten Hälfte nicht mehr scharf. Und das ist dann schon etwas, mit dem ich nicht gerechnet habe, dass die so einstürzen plötzlich. Wir haben vor zwei Wochen noch die Diskussion mit einem Arsenal-Scout gehabt und mit Uli im Podcast. Uli meinte, die werden Klarmeister. Der Scout meinte, die werden Klarmeister. Ich war mir ziemlich sicher, dass City das noch machen wird, weil die haben einfach die Erfahrung. Die haben in den letzten Jahren immer wieder solche Rückstände aufgeholt, sogar in höherer Größenordnung. Und dann kommt das noch dazu, dass die natürlich psychologisch dieses Spielchen schon 100 Mal durch haben. Und die Ganners jetzt natürlich wieder in der Drucksituation sind. Das ist ja ganz klar.
Wenn ich mir jetzt – ich konnte es gestern leider nicht sehen, das Spiel, und es war ja auch interessant, dass es parallel zur Champions League angesetzt war. Deswegen muss ich mich jetzt quasi auf deine Beurteilung verlassen und habe nur die Statistiken. Aber da ist mir eben eine ins Auge gestochen. Also am Ende schießt City drei Tore, hat insgesamt neun Schüsse. Arsenal hatte nur zehn Schüsse. Aber was mich wirklich umgehauen hat, war auch in diesem Spiel. Arsenal eindeutig die Mannschaft im Ballbesitz. 64 Prozent und Manchester City, die jetzt auch nicht so ballbesitzfeindlich sind, mit 36 Prozent. War das eine taktische Maßgabe? War das ein Kniff von Pep Guardiola? Hat der Spielverlauf damit zu tun, dass in der 24. Minute es schon 1-0 für City steht? Wie würdest du das beurteilen?
Schon auch ein wenig. Aber City weiß auch, dass Arsenal, wenn man die köder, dass die einfach zu erwischen sind. Das muss man schon auch sagen. Das ist in dieser Saison immer mal wieder zu sehen gewesen. Die Ganners waren nicht schlecht, sondern sie hatten wirklich eigentlich viel Ballbesitz, hatten auch ein paar gute Phasen. Aber Adeta hat selbst gesagt, sie haben die falschen Räume bespielt, haben nicht verstanden, wo man spielen muss. Und wenn sie Chancen hatten, haben sie die einfach liegen lassen. Also entweder sie haben gar nicht abgeschlossen und dachten, sie können nochmal den Haken machen und dann den Schuss erst loswerden. Oder sie sind einfach gar nicht zum Schuss gekommen, weil einer zu spät gekommen ist. Oder dergleichen. Gerade in Ketia, da gab es sogar die Frage vom Journalisten, hätte der nicht sogar einen Head-Trick erzählen müssen. Also das ist ja das große Problem. Sie haben einfach vorne keinen, der momentan abdrückt. Gabriel Jesus fehlt, der es aber eigentlich auch nicht ist. In Ketia spielt er einfach richtig gut mit. Aber er ist einfach kein Abschlussspieler. Und selbst Zaka und Martinelli waren gestern Katastrophe. Das ist einfach das große Problem, dass sie gestern einfach nicht effizient genug waren. Und City war in der zweiten Halbzeit genau das. Es war mir einfach klar, dass wenn die aus der Pause rauskommen, dass City irgendwie – das war in den letzten Wochen immer so – die verpennen den Schlaf. Äh, die verschlafen den Startsof. Und in der zweiten Hälfte sind die dann richtig gut. Und genau so war es halt gestern auch wieder. Irgendwie hat sich es abgezeichnet, dass die dann einfach nochmal was drauflegen können und dass bei Arsenal dann eher es grübelnlos geht.
Wie ist denn so, dass Echo jetzt auf diese Schwächephase Arsenal ist und dann auch gleichzeitig da mit einhergehend ja auch eine Stärke von City, die ja auch noch ganz andere Themen haben? Also ich denke, wir müssen jetzt nicht absolut ins Detail einsteigen, weil dann sprengen wir diese Ligatour. Aber Manchester City wurde von der Liga verklagt. Kannst du da mal für diejenigen, die nur die Überschriften gelesen haben, ganz kurz sagen, um was geht es da? Und spielt das überhaupt jetzt eine Rolle, wenn jetzt über sportliche Themen bei City gerade gesprochen wird?
Okay, ich hatte sie die letzte Woche und muss schon sagen, ich glaube, dass das schon ein Faktor ist. Also sie sind in über 100 Fällen von der Premier League quasi ja angezeigt worden. Meistens Financial Fairplay. Sie haben Verträge nicht angegeben oder die Vertragsinhalte nicht angegeben oder falsch angegeben oder zu niedrig angegeben. Sei es mit Spielern, sei es mit Trainern, sei es auch mit Sponsoren. Und das natürlich dann logischerweise verschiebt es die Bilanz oder zumindest das bilanzielle Bild, dass die Premier League von diesem Verein hat und damit natürlich Financial Fairplay Regeln gebrochen. Jetzt hat die Liga schon ein bisschen zurückgerudern müssen, weil allein schon mal sechs Fälle davon nicht gerechtfertigt waren. Da hat natürlich jetzt City die Hoffnung, dass das so weitergeht, dass der eine oder andere Fall da beugtelt und das dann heißt, nee, ist nicht so. Ein Satz könnte aber wirklich zum Problem werden. Es ist der Scheich quasi gefragt worden, ob er irgendwie Geld reingepumpt hat. Er hat gesagt, nein, absolut nicht. So ist dieser Satz gewesen. Er hat quasi kein Geld über Etihad in den Verein gepumpt. So ist die Devise von ihm. Und das kann natürlich dann irgendwann mal zum Genickbruch werden, weil ich glaube, dass es – also die Engländer vermuten, dass das gelogen ist und vermuten, dass ihm das wirklich noch um die Ohren fliegt. Und jetzt muss man sich natürlich mal auf die Spieler einstellen. Ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass das Thema ist in der Mannschaft. Die werden mit Sicherheit nicht sagen, ach ist doch egal, wir spielen 100%-lich Champions League, wir werden 100%-lich Meister, weil die Punkte werden uns nicht abgezogen. Sondern ich glaube, dass das schon Thema ist, weil es ist nicht zum ersten Mal der Fall. Guardiola wird immer darauf angesprochen, Guardiola muss immer antworten, es steht überall. Ich bin mir schon sicher, dass das Thema ist und dass das mit Sicherheit ein bisschen für Unruhe sorgen wird. Dann gibt es natürlich die Geschichte mit Cancelo, Begräune, also immer wieder Ärger auch mit den Spielern oder Kritik an den Spielern. Dann nimmt er wieder mal einen raus. Es ist nicht ganz ruhig. Das, was ja eigentlich bei City immer so auf dieser retorten Insel der große Vorteil war, die hat eine Ruhe. Weil es einfach keiner irgendwie groß interessiert, dass keiner groß interessiert hat. Und das ist jetzt schon so ein bisschen raus. Das muss man schon sagen. Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass da ein bisschen mehr Druck ist als in den letzten Jahren. Trotzdem muss man halt sagen, Guardiola ist halt einfach ein klasse Trainer. Die Mannschaft ist klasse. Und gestern hat man an der Show gemerkt, die können sich dann halt irgendwann mal davon frei machen. Und haben einfach dann diese unglaubliche Klasse, das dann zu Ende zu spielen. Ich hab's gestern dem Cutter, der neben mir saß, ich muss das zusammenfassen für Sky. Schau dir das mal an, in der Bundesliga wären diese drei Tore nicht gefallen. Weil da hätte irgendjemand auch abgedreht, da hätte irgendjemand gewartet, gezögert. Die haben einfach wirklich diese Schlagfertigkeit, dann in dem Moment das sauber zu Ende zu spielen, mit dieser unglaublichen Klasse und diese Dinger rein zu machen. Und das ist wirklich einfach wahnbrechend, muss man klar sagen. Und Jack Greenlister in der Kritik stand, der macht dieses Tor als wär's nichts. Ein Haarland braucht eine Sekunde, um den Abschluss zu wählen, macht das perfekt. Und auch, schau dir das wirklich mal an, das erste Tor von de Boijne, Tome Yasso spielt den Ball zurück, und genau, de Boijne rennt da rein. 90 Prozent der Spieler, die ich kenne, hätten den entweder auf die Tribüne gehauen, oder sie hätten einfach gesagt, ach, ich schieß gar nicht erst. Der macht mit seinem schwachen linken Fuß über den Torwart drüber, in einer absoluten Klasse-Manier. Die haben halt einfach wirklich eine gute Truppe, muss man halt sagen.
Ja gut, und da greifen ja dann die beiden Themen auch ineinander, wenn man das bei Ninja Fair Play umgeht. Dann ist es auch einfacher, eine gute Gruppe zusammenzustellen, wenn man dann auch wirklich viel Geld hat. Jetzt hast du gerade Cancello und de Bruyne kurz angesprochen. Ich glaube, Cancello, das haben wir alle mitbekommen. Das war durchaus erstaunlich, dass jemand, der noch vor wenigen Jahren oder vor kurzer Zeit einer der besten Außenverteidiger der Liga war, dass der zum FC Bayern wechselt. Und das hat ja ganz offensichtlich mit dem Binnenverhältnis zu tun zwischen ihm und Pep Guardiola und vielleicht auch ihm und der Mannschaft beziehungsweise der Angst, dass da etwas abfärben könnte. Du hast De Bruyne jetzt auch noch genannt, das habe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht mitbekommen. Gibt es da ein ähnliches Thema?
Ja, also der hat ihn mal angezählt, ich glaube nach dem Brighton-Spiel, also vor dem Brighton-Spiel glaube ich, da hat er gesagt, dass ihm die eine oder andere Einstellung nicht gefällt und dass deswegen auch der eine oder andere Spieler mal nicht spielt. Da war wohl De Bruyne gemeint. Und dann hat er ihn ja in den beiden Totten im Spielen, die ja jetzt vor diesem Arsene-Spiel nicht unwichtiger waren, um eben zurückzukommen, da hat er ihn auch auf die Bank gesetzt und in einem Spiel sogar 90 Minuten auf der Bank sitzen lassen. Und das ist natürlich dann schon etwas, wo viele gesagt haben, okay, also Kevin De Bruyne in so einem wichtigen Spiel 90 Minuten auf der Bank sitzen zu lassen, ist schon ein Zeichen. Und da war eben wohl so, dass der Tenor, dass er nicht genug nach hinten gearbeitet hat, dass ihm die Einstellung nicht so gefallen hat und dass er deswegen mal ein Zeichen setzen wollte. Und er hat es auch immer wieder gesagt eben, dass De Bruyne hier schon wichtig ist, aber dass ihm momentan halt das nicht so gefällt, wie er arbeitet.
Wir werden es im Blick behalten. Ich meine, der große Unterschied zwischen Arsenal und City ist auch die Spielbelastung in den kommenden Wochen. Also City spielt ja unter anderem in der Champions League bei Rasenbeilsport Leipzig und wird ja dann eventuell noch weiter vertreten sein in diesem Wettbewerb. Und im FA Cup ist man auch noch mit dabei, während Arsenal sich auf die Liga konzentrieren darf, Schreckstrich muss und dann eben versuchen kann, diese Serie, die jetzt vier Spiele umfasst, in denen man dreimal verloren hat und einmal unentschieden gespielt hat, irgendwie zu drehen. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was sich da noch entwickelt. Da sind wir uns wahrscheinlich einig. Gibt es noch etwas zu Arsenal zu sagen, was dir auf dem Herzen liegt, bevor wir mit dem nächsten Thema weitermachen?
Ich glaube, dass Arsenal jetzt schon ein psychologisches Problem hat. Du hast jetzt verloren dieses direkte Duell. Du bist jetzt punktgleich. Ja, du hast ein Spiel weniger. Aber man muss schon sagen, du bist jetzt plötzlich vom Gejagten zum Jäger geworden irgendwo im Kopf, glaube ich. Und jetzt den Kopf nochmal hochzufahren und zu sagen, okay, wir starten das jetzt alles nochmal in diesem Moment der Enttäuschung, wo du ja eher im Kopf hast, ich glaube, das war es. Das ist jetzt die Schwierigkeit. Also wenn diese junge Mannschaft das hinbekommt, Respekt. Aber einfach, glaube ich, ist das nicht. Jetzt nochmal zu sagen, okay, wir waren ganz oben. Jetzt sind wir eingeholt worden. Jetzt muss man nochmal anfangen. Jetzt werden wir es nochmal allen zeigen. Das ist das Teil der Champions aus. Das ist genau das, was City eigentlich gemacht hat. Und jetzt ist die Frage, ob Arsenal das auch schon im Kreuz hat, wirklich zu sagen, in dieser Phase jetzt erst recht. Das ist wirklich jetzt die absolute Königsdisziplin. Und das ist die jüngste Mannschaft der Liga. Sie das können, ist die Frage. Ich sage nicht, dass sie es nicht können, aber jetzt wird sich wirklich die schöne Spreu von Weizen drin.
Und gleichzeitig muss man sagen, dieser Nachholtermin, das war ja, glaube ich, wegen des Tods der Queen, das dieses Spiel verschoben wurde. Das ist natürlich nochmal so ein zusätzlicher, naja, das macht es einfach für die Fans schwer verdaulich, weil man schon die These aufstellen kann, bleibt dann immer eine Hypothese, kann man nicht überprüfen, dass man damals, hätte das Spiel damals stattgefunden, vielleicht bessere Chancen gehabt hätte, als jetzt, wo man eben aus einer Schwächephase kommend eben schon gegen City spielen musste. Aber so ist es eben manchmal. Wir wollen noch über den FC Southampton sprechen und für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die sich wundern, warum kommt jetzt hier Southampton? Naja, das könnte unter anderem mit dem Tabellenplatz zusammenhängen, denn die liegen auf dem allerletzten Platz, haben nur 15 Punkte. Für vier Punkte Rückstand sind es auf Leeds United, die aktuell auf dem ersten Nicht-Abstiegsplatz liegen. Was ist bei Southampton los?
Ich habe den Trainer entlassen, Nathan Jones, und dann war es eben so gut wie sicher, dass eigentlich Jesse Marsh der neue Trainer wird, der bei Leeds erst wenige Tage zuvor entlassen worden ist, der ehemalige RB-Trainer. Und der wird es jetzt offensichtlich nicht. Knackpunkt ist scheinbar die Vertragslänge, was man so liest. Aber es ist halt sehr kurios, weil auf Hasen Rüttel, der ja eigentlich ein gestandener Trainer war weltweit, einen Trainer geruht hat, der mit Nathan Jones, der ein besserer Zweitliga-Trainer war, der bei Stoke es nicht geschafft hat, irgendwie etwas hinzubekommen und eigentlich nur in Looten funktioniert hat. Und der dann halt am Schluss sehr krude und sehr wirre Interviews gegeben hat mit Aussagen wie, ich bin nicht schuld, sondern im Endeffekt durfte ich ja nicht ich selbst sein und ich war ein anderer und musste ein anderer sein, aber jetzt werde ich wieder ich selbst sein. Und dann, als er selbst war, lief es noch viel schlimmer. Und dann auch letztendlich gedroppt hat, wie ich bin statistisch gesehen der beste Trainer Europas. Wo man sich halt wirklich die Frage stellt, was ist denn eigentlich mit dem los? Und Uli kam eigentlich, der hatte jetzt auf dem ein paar Mal, der kam jedes Mal raus und kam zu mir und sagte, ey, was der schon wieder für Interviews gegeben hat, du musst dir das mal anhören. Weil der einfach komplett neben der Spur ist. Und so hat die Mannschaft auch gespielt. Und das große Problem ist halt, nach dieser Hasenütterentlassung, wo du ja eigentlich gewusst hast, es geht runter in der Tabelle, dass du dann halt sagst, wir gönnen uns ein Projekt, bei dem wir nicht wissen, ob der schon dieses Premier League Format hat. Damit hast du jetzt einfach halt einen Monat, glaube ich, war er jetzt im Amt, oder ich weiß keine wie viele Monate, das hast du einfach verloren. Das hast du einfach verloren. So easy ist es. Seit November, gut, 14 Spiele. Du hast einfach Zeit verloren. Du musst jetzt wieder von vorn anfangen, jemanden zu finden, der dir hilft. Und da ist das große Problem einfach, Southampton hat da, glaube ich, die Situation nicht ganz richtig verstanden, und sind jetzt tabellnetzter.
Und dann ist es ja auch einigermaßen skurril, deswegen habe ich nämlich extra den Abstand Solic United nochmal genannt, dass man dann eben denjenigen Premier holen möchte im ersten Versuch, der da gerade entlassen wurde. Hängt das damit zusammen, dass eben sowohl Jesse Marsch als auch Ralf Hasenhüttl eben aus der viel beachteten Red Bull-Familie kommen? Ich habe jetzt ehrlicherweise von den letzten Spielen nicht mehr verfolgt, deswegen weiß ich nicht, wie umschaltlastig das noch war und wie pressinglastig und so weiter. Also geht es da quasi darum, oder wie ist man auf den Gedanken gekommen, dass jemand, der bei einem anderen Verein, der direkte Abstiegskonkurrent ist, nicht funktioniert hat, auf einmal die Lösung für Southampton sein könnte?
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Ich glaube, das Narrativ war, um Marsch immer so quasi, naja, es sah ja gut aus, sie haben sich einfach nur nicht belohnt. Und ich weiß schon auch, dass aus erster Hand, dass in Southampton neue Bosse quasi dran sind oder zumindest ein neuer Sportdirektor und dass dort einfach schon ein bisschen progressiver gearbeitet werden soll. Das ist so dieses Ding. Und Jesse Marsch passt natürlich schon irgendwo hin, weil, wie du eben gesagt hast, Hasenlüttel ließ ja auch so ein Umschaltfußball spielen. Sehr intensiv drauf. Die Mannschaft ist schon so ein wenig darauf ausgerichtet. Das könnte schon funktionieren. Bei Lieds war es halt so, dass die sich einfach nicht belohnt haben. Das muss man schon sagen. Aber auch da hat uns ein anderer Scout, nicht der, sondern der hat uns gesagt, das kannst du dir oder das konntest du dir am Schluss nicht mehr ansehen. Du kriegst Kopfschmerzen, weil es eigentlich nur intensives Draufrumpeln war. Und wenn die den Ball gewonnen haben, hatten die null Plan. Weil sie dann einfach gesagt haben, okay, jetzt müssen wir eigentlich was damit anfangen, was Kreatives. Und es hat nichts mehr mit Intensität zu tun, sondern mit Kreativität. Und das haben sie überhaupt nicht hinbekommen.
Und kannst du noch kurz was zum Club Southampton sagen? Was würde das für die Premier League bedeuten, wenn Southampton wieder absteigt, muss man dazu sagen? Also Southampton ist ein Urgestein, war nicht komplett seit der Gründung. Der First Division dabei. Aber im Grunde ab dann, dann auch immer in der Premier League. Und dann gab es eben schon einmal diese Phase 2005, 2006, bis eben dann 2012, in der man in der zweiten Liga war. Das heißt, wir reden hier von einem Traditionsclub.
Ja, das ist ein absoluter Traditionsverein. Und natürlich würde der fehlen. Aber man muss halt schon sagen, dass natürlich die anderen Vereine, das ist so ein bisschen wie in der Bundesliga vergleichbar, dass sie natürlich schon ein wenig da an Boden verlieren, weil dann andere Clubs mehr Geld zur Verfügung haben. Das ist so wirklich so ein Phänomen aller Bundesliga-Traditionsverein, der halt verhältnismäßig normale Mittel hat. Wahrscheinlich für Bundesliga-Verhältnisse wäre es immer noch viel. Aber der verhältnismäßig normale Mittel hat. Und plötzlich kommen dann halt welche von links und rechts und investieren da mal mehr und investieren da mal mehr. Und das ist natürlich schon das große Problem, dass sie sich da halt sehen. Arsene Lütl hat immer gesagt, wir müssen so in der Range 10 bis 15 Millionen Euro verpflichten, weil wir haben einfach keine andere Chance. Und wir können auch keines aus England holen, sondern wir müssen nach Frankreich, Niederlande und dergleichen, weil nur dort für uns ein funktionierender Markt entstanden ist. Und das sieht man ja schon. Also ich glaube, dass die meisten Premier-Ligisten da nicht dran denken, zu sagen, wir gehen jetzt nur nach Frankreich und holen da Spieler, weil wir es jetzt leisten können. Die sind schon ein wenig abgeschlagen, das muss man schon sagen. Das ist alles so ein bisschen grau geworden mittlerweile. Aber hatten halt das Glück, dass sie durch Hasenwürttel und den Fußball immer mal wieder irgendwo ein Dreier oder ein Pünktchen geholt haben. Das war manchmal auch Drama. Die sind manchmal auch untergegangen. Diese 2-mal mit neuen Gegentoren, werdet ihr alle wissen. Das konnte auch passieren. Aber im Grunde genommen gab es immer noch genug Spiele, wo sie Punkte holen konnten, weil sie dann einfach mal wieder einfach richtig nervig waren. Auch gegen City zum Beispiel habe ich mal ein Spiel gehabt, wo sie dann auch gewonnen haben. Das gab es schon auch mal, dass die die Großen geärgert haben. Das hat sich dann immer so ein bisschen gerettet. Aber wenn du natürlich da jetzt aktuell, sieht es halt wirklich sehr planlos aus. Und alles auf junge Spieler getrimmt, ist ja okay. Kann funktionieren, ist eben eine Basis. Aber dann brauchen die halt einen Konstrukt. Und wenn da mit Nathan Jones einer ist, der einfach die Liga nicht verstanden hat, der dann auch wirklich wirr daherkommt, dann verstreicht Zeit und du holst keine Punkte. Und das kannst du dir halt dann einfach da unten nicht erlauben.
Gut, wir werden es beobachten, wie es weitergeht bei Southampton. Jetzt habe ich allen bisherigen Gästen dieselbe Frage gestellt. Die bekommst auch du zum Abschluss, lieber Jogi. Welches Spiel an diesem Wochenende sollten wir denn unbedingt mitverfolgen? Und du darfst jetzt nicht mit United gegen Barca heute Abend antworten. Das hat nämlich Alex Truica schon gemacht.
Ich kommentiere Aston Villa gegen Arsenal. Bin ich sehr gespannt, bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt, wie Arsenal jetzt reagiert. Das interessiert mich sehr. Newcastle gegen Liverpool ist interessant, weil natürlich das da oben so ein Duell ist. Newcastle kann denen schon richtig Ärger machen. Selbig ist es Tottenham gegen West Ham, das kommentiere ich auch am Sonntag. Das interessiert mich auch sehr, weil man schon sagen muss, dass Tottenham jetzt verloren ist gegen Leicester, die richtig untergegangen sind. Und wie es da mit Antonio Conte weitergeht, dessen Mundwinkel immer weiter nach unten geht, bei dem ich mir ziemlich sicher bin, dass er nach der Saison hinschmeißen wird, das interessiert mich auch, wie es da weitergeht. Es sind ein paar Duellen, aber auf Arsenal und El Esten Villa freue ich mich besonders, weil ich will die Reaktionen sehen. Ich bin echt gespannt, ob meine Theorie, dass die gegen El Esten Villa jetzt schon einen drauf kriegen und da jetzt schon einen brechen, bin gespannt, ob ich recht habe oder ob ich unrecht habe. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass ich unrecht habe, weil dann bleibt es spannend.
Dann bleibt es spannend. Wir werden es sehen können am 18. Februar. Das ist der Samstag. Es ist das frühe Spiel. 13.30 Uhr dann Anpfiff. Jogi, ich danke dir ganz herzlich. Wie immer der Hinweis. Ihr könnt natürlich auch im eigenen Podcast von Jogi und Uli das genauer hören. Plus eben, da bekommt man auch Arsenal-Scouts zu hören, was jetzt auch ein bisschen untypisch ist für viele Podcasts. Ich danke dir, dass du hier mit dabei warst.
Immer wieder gerne für dich.
Das freut mich zu hören und ich danke dann auch nochmal stellvertretend Alex Truica, Christian Bernhard und Alexis Menuge und stellvertretend eben auch für alle anderen, die immer in der Ligatur mitmachen. Und ich danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, dass ihr der Ligatur treu bleibt und dass ihr den Rasenfunk unterstützt. Tut das bitte, denn so können wir wachsen. Und dann gibt es auch solche Formate, die gibt es wirklich öfter, wenn der Rasenfunk ein bisschen wachsen kann. Ihr werdet in den nächsten Wochen hoffentlich merken, wie ich das gemeint habe. Ich möchte es noch nicht verraten, denn hinterher klappt es nicht. Ansonsten habt eine gute Zeit und bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.